mais d'abord la campagne de vaccination
contre le coc vide 19 va-t-elle enfin
décoller c'est en tout cas ce qu'espère
le gouvernement avec l'entrée en piste
cette semaine des soignants de plus de
50 ans à tour trois centres dédiés sont
ouverts l'enjeu est de taille désamorcée
par l'exemple les craintes des français
le reportage à l'hôpital bretonneau de
samuel colin de maladies covit dans les
trois mois du tout et pas de contacter
un médecin et beaucoup de journalistes
pour cette opération de communication du
chu
depuis hier la vaccination au centre de
consultation des voyageurs est ouverte
aux professionnels de santé de plus de
50 ans et se demandent 50 ans avec des
comorbidités ici à l'hôpital trousseau
où rue géhanne fouquet il suffit de
prendre rendez vous par téléphone ou
internet
le protocole commence par un
questionnaire sur l'état de santé
général qu'aujourd'hui vous soyez en
forme pas en cours d'infection pas
fébrile pas malade il y a le fait que
vous n'ayez pas d'antécédents récent
decaux vides puisqu'il faut à trad au
delà trois mois du d'une infection par
le cos vite pour pouvoir accéder à la
vaccination
après l'injection 15 minutes d'attentes
en observation au cas où il ya eu une
réaction fièvre ou allergies il en faut
plus pour sept médecins venus en renfort
cette année deux personnes de son
entourage sont décédées des suites du
coc vie de 10,9 mais moi j'ai plus
beaucoup beaucoup plus peur du virus que
du vaccin figurez vous parce que je sais
que les bacs ça ça fait pas mourir alors
je sais que le virus a fait mourir la
vaccination est ouverte à 2500 personnes
au chu
sans compter les soignants et médecins
de ville ce matin
force est de constater le peu
d'affluence il ya une défiance sur la
vaccination au fond c'est quoi
ce sujet est connue simplement le coc
vide et quand même quelque chose
d'inédit dans nos vies qui doit nous
inviter aussi à réfléchir aux risques
qu'on a envie de prendre ou pas être
faire prendre aux autres prochaines
étapes d'ici 15 jours a priori les plus
de 75 ans aurait pas d' les personnes
fragiles ainsi que l'ensemble des
soignants